being nominated for acm entertainer of
the year is just
um it's just amazing i mean i look back
over my career
and i've won a couple of entertainer of
the year awards and every time you see
your name a part of that group of people
you're just honored by it and i tell you
what i mean
i go on stage every night trying to be
the best entertainer i can be
and trying to make everybody in the
crowd in the room
sing and love one another and have fun
and so anytime the acms recognizes me
for that
it's a dream come true
i mean i think it's incredible to be
nominated for acm entertainer of the
year you know
something that i'll never take for
granted um it's something that
you know not too many folks have
achieved and a club that i'm proud to be
a part of and
you know when or not i just hope to be
in the conversation i think entertainer
of the year
even just being nominated is such a
human experience i think every artist
when they start out
that's kind of their their dream that's
kind of their goal at least it was mine
um i started this career in 2010 i
always dreamed of being nominated for
this award
um and uh this will be my second time
being nominated at the acms it's just uh
unbelievable because there's so much
work that goes into putting on this show
with your band with your crew and
just looking at all the countless hours
we've spent you know getting our show
right making sure people have the time
their lives at our concert has been
has been a ton of work but to be
nominated it is a really nice a really
nice
just pat on the back you know it's it's
uh it's something that i've dreamed
about for a long time and now that
now that i'm being nominated for this
award it's just it just continues to be
mind-blowing